Sì aiuto aiuto aiuto
Mi stai seguendo
ora arriva la parte più difficile
un'ora inizia
Scappiamo dalla casa del signor paura
il signor paura che potete vedere qua è
un nuovo cattivo pauroso spaventoso
brutto capisco sei una sorta di robot
che cos'è un background comunque
dovremmo scappare dalla sua villa dalla
sua casa come sempre lasciate un bel mi
piace Mettetevi comodi prendi popcorn
qualcosa da bere qualcosa da mangiare
iniziamo subito questa nuova Escape Room
vediamo un buio esplorare La casa del
signor paura signor paura sembra qui
sotto il suo piedistallo è un po'
particolare effettivamente e che brutto
Non avvicinarti troppo però eh ancora le
mani le mani sono tipo di metallo
ragione È tipo un robot Sì anche la
faccia tipo gli manca un pezzo che si
vede dentro che c'è un ingranaggio da
questa parte che brutto il camino con le
sbarre e ha imprigionato il fuoco
e poi questa è una giornata col basilico
Che cos'è questo il basilico
dovremmo capire dove siamo esattamente
fuori non ci riesco cosa ci sarà in
questa porta dovremmo prendere cliccare
questa maniglia che cosa è successo eh
Tu sei riuscito a uscire dalla porta
perché qua avevi fatto cadere qua giù
Oh no Ecco il signor paura
non gli piace che il suo sonno venga
interrotto noi lo lasciamo dormire
tranquillo figurati
[Musica]
riproviamo Speriamo che non si accorga
che sto passando di qua c'è scritto papà
Ah beh lo sapevo già che dovevo correre
io
aiuto aiuto aiuto
Aiuto
Sono rimasta incastrata nel muro Ok
Questa volta dobbiamo farcela si è
svegliato un po' in ritardo oggi
avevamo un po' più di sonno e quindi ha
messo una sveglia più tardi e forse ce
la posso fare allora Ah aiuto dai dai
dai dai dai dai Ma quando si stanca di
seguirmi basta
Dov'è Eccolo lì Continua continua
ti manca poco
forse ce l'ha fatta visto incastrando
Vai prova arrivo arrivo arrivo
qui dietro l'angolo
Non c'è modo di sfuggirmi dicendo
io Vitale siamo esperti nello scappare o
no che cosa c'è qua Ci sono tipo dei
rulli macinatori se cadiamoci ma girerà
qua fatti tutti a pezzettini Sì ok
passato i laser con gli spuntoni Oh ma
perché devono sempre esserci laser Io li
odio i laser almeno non si muovono
strano
stare
allora adesso mi metto qui e mi godo lo
spettacolo vediamo come sfracellata
davanti prossimo stage e ci sono
tantissime persone che stanno giocando a
questo gioco ho visto che ci sono 5.000
persone connesse a questo gioco
alle scale piace cambiare ricordate che
ha superato
più avanti ormai ci sono anch'io qui
via Sono matti dai sfracellate Vitale
Uffa Sono troppo bravo Ogni volta che
dico sfracellate Vitale
riproviamo Ma come ma non ho neanche
sfiorata adesso sbrigati è facile
concentrazione
cosa perché io sto camminando invece non
riesco a capire
Ehi ma tu stai facendo tutto
lentissimamente Stai andando piano piano
attento Qua è pieno di trappole davvero
Chissà se una di queste trappole
prendere a Vitale Spero di sì
Ehi non mi vedi sono qua Ehi cos'è
lontanissima Non mi dire che sei ancora
lì nella scivolo e mi sto facendo una
passeggiatina adesso corrono
Oh cazzo del signor paura e tu fai
lentamente
Allora ci sono ci sono ah ah
amo Dai questa volta invece ce la faccio
vediamo eh anche l'altro giocatore non
se la sta cavando molto bene
[Musica]
triturato Io andrò avanti qua invece no
adesso ce la faccio Ce lo faccio per
davvero Oh no qua c'è una una macina
tutto Immagina tutto Sì e non lo so È
tipo un frullatore stiamo dentro un
frullatore
o no Premi il pulsante
Vai eri tu quello che hai trovato io
sono qui dietro di te Poverino quel
personaggio è stato attrezzato dobbiamo
premere questo bottone Sì c'è scritto di
premerlo anche qua proviamo
non è una trappola vero diventeremo dei
frullati per il dottor paura no dottore
No non era il dottore signore
la
super velocità Cioè tipo la foresta
proibita laggiù la vedete vedo gli occhi
degli alberi ci
sono gli alberi vediamo la prima teniamo
addirittura la Capriolo l'ho fatto no
troppo bello più Wow
bellissimo la capriola
quanto di troppo pallida idea Ah ah ah
la vita reale non è facile come sembra
però è troppo divertente mi piace questa
super velocità e poi tutti questi alberi
con gli occhi rossi sono fighissimi
No
guarda il dottor paura signor paura è lì
ma è diventato Celeste tipo che gli è
successo
Non lo so forse è diventato un altro
robot
[Musica]
sfracella
bisogna fare tutto per velocissimamente
Ci sono quasi ci sono quasi attento lì
c'è un portale non so dove riuscivo
dall'altra parte Uh Eccoti perché si è
sfracellata per terra Ok Dove siamo
dentro dentro il signor paura ah ci ha
mangiato fuori che ci stava inseguendo
come abbiamo fatto noi ad entrare dentro
Ma uffa
usa queste casse per costruire
con le casse credo un passaggio per
andare dall'altra parte vediamo
Guardate qui perché sono rimasto
bloccato Ok
vediamo se riesco a salire adesso perché
c'ho il bottone rosso Ok ho capito
Sì una sopra l'altra così poi esci ma io
ne metto uno a fianco all'altra senza
salire forse ho sbagliato qualcosa Ok
prendiamo la terza scatola Sì ce l'ho
fatta non ne sono sicuro di aver fatto
proprio un ottimo lavoro
di riuscire a passare sì forse sì No non
ce l'ho fatta L'importante è che riesce
a salire sopra
Ecco la vita Ciao Andiamo 3 ore dopo è
riuscito a mettere le scatole
zipline E ora questi cosa sono laser o
tipo acido
no pure io mi sono sfracellato usa i
Baustelle qui sotto per attraversarli
Quindi mi devo buttare là sotto posso
girarmi Ok ma tum wow wow
troppo figo Ronaldo sta volando
ma che proviamo Wow
fighissimo
e aspetta Ma perché ci siamo sfracellati
lì ma tu Forse dovevamo andare da
un'altra parte Rossa qui credo Sì sì
è super difficile che figo
a salire su quello rosso dai puoi
farcela Riprova Eccomi Oh ce l'ho fatta
Dove sono gli altri esatto
via Primo salto
secondo salto ora il più difficile
questo
terzo
vogliosata salta salta non devi saltare
la palla lì dietro devi saltare in
avanti non indietro non è vero abbiamo
Riproviamo
no no no no no no no
[Musica]
OK Prova a Vitale al posto mio perché io
sono troppo schiappa e questi tappetini
di Masini quindi vediamo vediamo
[Musica]
ora arriva la parte più difficile
non ci sei neanche arrivato alla parte
più difficile rullo di tamburi l'ultimo
salto
Wow Sembra un'illusione ottica
gira tutto tutto
fighissimo che cosa succede Non ti
azzardare perché poi magari non abbiamo
salvato e devo rifare pure il tappeto ho
capito che cos'è tipo una grattugia
gigante che gira se tu cadi viene tutto
grattugiato lì
sta provando in ogni modo a farci
affette mangiarci
No no pure sono caduto non mi dire che
era iniziata lì non mi dire che
all'inizio dalle No Meno male non devo
rifare quella parte Ok Anzi dobbiamo
fare solo questi anelli di cipolla
sono caduto Sì ho capito
Ho fame non è facile passare qua
effettivamente
Aiuto Ho capito come funziona No
è abbastanza difficile questa Escape
Room devo dire
Ah l'hai Vitale ancora laggiù non ce la
faccio cado sempre devo correre a
salvare Ah no a salvarmi a salvare
perché non voglio rifare tutto quello un
portale Ecco Vitale è stata fatta a
superare quello stage guarda lì c'è il
signor paura o come l'impressione che
questo sia l'ultimo stage dovremo
affrontarlo come l'impressione che stia
per
Oh no cosa dobbiamo colpire Sì con cosa
con quest'arma che ci ha dato sono tipo
delle
bombe dobbiamo sparargli bellissima vita
Ah aiuto
è la testa si è staccata Guarda che
brutta
è bruttissimo la testa apro abbiamo già
i progressi siamo riusciti
Dimmi almeno se no non ce l'abbiamo
fatta allora aiuta Che brutto Uh uh uh
wow
Spero di riuscire a sconfiggerlo anch'io
è troppo veloce aiuto
ci ha preso no ha fatto quel rotolamento
questa volta dobbiamo sconfiggere il
signor paura Mister Fieri Vai Via Vai
via Che brutto che sei allontanati Dai
dai Non ti manca poco aiuto
o no Ora inizia Yu yu che ha affettato
con gli occhiali c'ho gli occhi laser
pure quindi oltre arrotolamento farà
anche gli occhi laser Mmm ma è troppo
forte allora colpiscilo subito appena
arrivi lì appiccati Questo Beccati
questo
cliccate questo è proprio di bere la
birra io non lo stai colpendo Dai Katia
Hai preso l'hai preso l'hai preso dove
non ti vedo più qua c'è un altro portale
presta andiamo nel portale sì dove sei
Ma non ti vedo io la Anita Eccomi sono
qua non mi vedi ciao Eccoti Sì sì sì sì
fuga traversa la foresta
Wow Adoro le foreste sarà la foresta
proibita ci sarà un altro un altro
Mister paura Ci sono dei funghi
fluorescenti meglio non toccarli non
pensare di mangiarli Eh no guarda non ti
farò niente
sono delle nude i funghi luminosi Non ti
fidare È meglio non fidarsi che cosa ci
sarà in questa foresta Ma che cosa c'è
qua dietro
c'è nessuno è troppo strano che non c'è
nessuno è troppo facile
Qualcosa mi dice che spunterà qualcosa
di paurosi
Ecco perché c'era qualcosa che non
andava andava no no no no no no no no
ti ho visto che ti ha spiaccicato
proprio di fronte a me ma poi non arriva
subito Ah ecco le laggiù aiuto Eccolo là
E tu dove sei e io sono più o meno
all'inizio ma spero di farcela Ehi sono
in vantaggio Sì avevo solo saltare
Addio Mr paura a non rivederci mai più
sorprese oh no dove sono finita Solo che
poi non lo stagno in un Non lo so Sto
nuotando dell'acqua verde putridata
poi ho sceso quasi c'è scritto qualcosa
salta Sì salta salta
cosa fantastica e poi devi nuotare Ah sì
lo vedo lo vedo tutto dentro c'è il
badge credo ma ma non si vede niente
nell'acqua putrida Eh sì infatti ti devi
tipo saltare così Sì se salti riesci a
vedere dove stai andando
però laggiù ci sono io gigante quindi
sicuramente quello il badge e avremo
vinto ma non riesco a capire più niente
dove sono Ma come Ma tu stai andando
sott'acqua devi andare sopra Ah ok sennò
non capisci niente
Cioè tipo stavo scendendo sott'acqua
profondissimamente
Eccoci qua dov'è Vitale Ecco allora
aiuto però devi anche andare avanti Non
è che salti e basta ah ah perché non sto
andando avanti
stavo camminando sull'acqua non so che è
successo mi vedo mi vedo gigante in
fondo Quanto manca
il peggio finalmente
Uh sono riuscito ad uscire dall'acqua
punto di domanda Qua c'è Mr paura però
non credo che ci inseguate Puglia Sì hai
preso peggio hai preso il tè verde ma di
poco
Guarda qua forse ci possiamo prendere
il signor paura vediamo No io non mi
voglio trasformarla nel signor paura
ah Che paura
il diavolo
[Applauso]
e basta mangiare Mangi troppo adesso ti
prendo anch'io mi sono trasformato
adesso Your Boss Beccati questo Beccati
questo Beccati questo
Escape Room mancata casa lasciate un bel
mi piace Ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite eh Buona visione Ciao